he is one of only two people besides me
to speak at every single new york r
conference
uh him and dan chen have spoken at every
single one of them
which is all the more remarkable because
the next one's probably most famous for
python and actually i realized dan chen
wrote a python book right but dan chen
does both languages and now
our next speaker does too
i used to have a lot of fun trolling him
at these conferences
it doesn't feel the same we're not in
person but also he's contributed so much
to the art community now
it doesn't feel right to troll him don't
get me wrong as soon as we're back in
person i will start trolling him again i
will absolutely have a fun time doing
this just because you know that's what
you do to you to a good friend you troll
them when they're in enemy territory but
he's not really enemy territory anymore
because he's contributed so much to our
community now that you know we can't
just make fun of him for being mr python
um so
i i want to sing his praise a little bit
more and i joke about python but he is
the reason python became a data science
language without wes i don't think that
would happen so we all oh the data
science community owes him gratitude for
that but he's since moved on to doing
even more stuff that's also been
transformative of the data science
community so he's had at least two
transformations of an entire field of
work so sorry if that was too much
praise and not enough trolling everyone
please welcome wes
thank you jared
thank you
all right
i'm live all right you can see me all
right let me
fix my fix my slides here
i i regret that we cannot be together in
person but i hope to see everyone at a
future
in person
new york on our conference i'll i'll uh
keep my fingers crossed for
uh for 20 for 2022.
um it's been it's been interesting to be
here every year and to be speaking about
very similar uh very similar topics um
but it's good and that each year passes
by and we have more and more interesting
things to talk about and definitely
a lot more work that is uh bringing
value to the r community and increasing
the kinds of things that uh
the increasing the computational
capabilities that are available for uh
for our programmers um so you know so as
jared says like i've become more of a
polyglot as time as time has gone on but
i you know that that was always the uh
the intention with the the aero project
so i'll share you some share with you
some of the new things that have been
going on and some of the things to
expect
over the coming year and and beyond that
you can use now and things that you can
get excited about
so for for those who
who are not aware the aero the aero
project
was conceived to provide a language
independent foundation for
uh for analytical computing focused on
on data frames and and tabular data it
wasn't just created for for the data
science ecosystem but was also intended
to bring better interoperability to to
database systems big data systems but
also to provide an efficient bridge
between the big data and database
systems world and the data science world
and since then we've been working on
doing development in the project
seemingly you know it feels like a long
time now but it has been a little over
five years of active development we had
maybe another six months of active
planning before that so i've been
working on the project for a little over
six years now
but it's it's grown to encompass
encompass many programming many
programming languages
and and
happily for data science users it has
become one of the de facto
if not the de facto standard technology
for connecting uh external data sources
to the to the data science world and for
getting data out of you know traditional
database systems data warehouses uh
being able to load data more quickly so
that we can work work more efficiently
and get more work done
in languages that we love like python
and r
um
i knew that starting out that that arrow
was uh was going to be a large large
project that required a lot of people i
started out the project uh with a large
group of open source collaborators i was
at i was at cloudera working with with
folks at
on projects like impala and kudu at
cloudera
i moved to new york in 2016
to join two sigma because two sigma was
really excited about arrow and it was
was offering a lot of sponsorship and
support for for my work
but in 2018 it became apparent that um
that aero was an important part of the
future growth of
uh the data science and database
ecosystem and there were many companies
including hardware companies other
financial firms that wanted to
wanted to support
uh support aero development and also
our studio said hey what about what
about r
and so we we came up with the idea to
create this cross kind of multi
um this industry consortium model to
fund aero development for a multi-year
period that was um
the most of the funding came from our
studio our studio also provided the
administrative support
for ursa labs but we were able to get
funding from a wide variety of sources
and that enabled us to to operate
a team of full-time developers building
out building out the aero project
building out integrations with
the data science languages so i would
say that ursa labs was was really
successful and enabled us to grow the
project
um to to where to where it is today
we realized
last year
that to enable arrow to reach its next
stage of growth
that large companies in order to adopt
arrow more wholeheartedly
in their systems
that there needs to be larger
large software companies with a larger
scope
that can build products and services to
support
uh enterprise adoption of aero
so we uh
we we saw a lot of we saw a lot of
interest in an adoption of aero use of
arrow and other and other software
products but the absence of a software
vendor
um a
that could support enterprises through
their adoption of aero was holding back
was what was holding back the ecosystem
so we pivoted from mrsa labs to ursa
computing we raised some venture capital
from
uh from our friends at gv uh to fund you
know to fund our growth so that that
occurred uh late last uh
early fall lat in 2020
um and we were able to grow continue to
grow the team throughout 2020 and early
2021
the the thing that kept me very busy
this year uh we there was we saw an
opportunity to bring together uh a
number of forces from
the aero ecosystem who had um had been
building
accelerated computational technology for
for apache aero in particular
computing pioneers from the gpu
computing world so folks
from the the rapids project as well as
blazing sql which is a distributed sql
engine built
on top of rapids and so we said to
ourselves you know we could have you
know disparate efforts to create
computing systems to bring
accelerated computing for aero users or
we could bring all of these forces under
a common a common umbrella to create uh
unified technologies unified systems um
to make it uh to make it easier for
people to use to use arrow everywhere
and so we we have called this new
company kind of uh reflecting the
joining together of of forces
uh we've called this company voltron
data and we are working uh we're growing
a large team
we have you know we have around we have
around 50 people
and we are working for the benefit of
the apache aero ecosystem the growth and
adoption of the project
as well as creating optimized
algorithms and computing technologies
across programming languages
and hardware and everything is based on
apache arrow
reflecting the change in uh the change
in name um and the change in our the
expanded scope of our mission uh ursa
labs lives on as uh as as voltron labs
and we will continue to
uh to grow and uh develop our open
source team and our relationship with
other open source projects
and take on and take on sponsorship and
funding for
for our open source our open source work
uh in the the aero project as well as
the the greater you know the aero
cinematic universe as it is uh now
turning into
um
so so back to back to arrow um so when
we started out building arrow we
developed a
language independent universal columnar
data format for data frames and other
another tabular data and the idea was to
standardize the memory representation so
that data could be shared portably
across programming languages
and that we could also share algorithms
between
different computing environments so
rather than having to serialize data
every time you move data between a
different environment we have a common a
common data representation that can be
shared without any copying or conversion
between java and c plus plus or rust and
go
or
python or r and javascript
and so that might be sharing data within
process or
or moving data
from process to process and we've
developed protocols and interfaces to
enable
seamless interoperability at those
language and system boundaries
and the the growth you know the the
growth in the community we now have
uh a dozen programming languages
represented
um some of the recent additions to uh to
the ecosystem include uh include matlab
and julia so we're very very excited
about that and we expect that things
will continue to grow rapidly there
the
in addition to the data format and
libraries that we've built for getting
data into that format so many our users
are familiar with
our arrow has unlocked the ability to to
read parquet files and so we we read
data into arrow format from par k and
then we load it into r from there
but arrow has spawned a number of
additional sub-projects and one that
we're really excited about that i've
spoken at this conference i've spoken
about at this conference in the past
is aeroflight which is designed to be a
new
network data transfer protocol
uh to replace um
old and slower uh interfaces for moving
data between systems so for example if
you're familiar with odbc
or jdbc we want to replace
those more inefficient
transfer protocols
interfaces to database systems with one
that is aero based so firstly if you
have two systems that if you have a
system that consumes arrow and you have
a system that can send arrow using
aeroflight then you don't have to do any
conversions when you receive the data
and so we would like to see as many uh
data storage systems and data warehouse
systems uh adopt aero as their uh adopt
aeroflight and be being able to deliver
aero data natively
to to aero users including people
working in python and r so when you pip
install
pi arrow in python you get a flight
client so you can connect to flight
servers
we've we've developed a prototype
interface to flight uh in r as well
and we we think this will be you know a
major source of growth to make it to
expand the number of data sources that
arrow users have access to natively
i would be remiss to mention that one of
the things that we are actively working
on in in the
in the open source project right now is
developing a standard for connecting to
sql databases with flight
aero flight is a low-level protocol
and does not contain any notions of sql
like user sessions prepared statements
and the other things that you would find
if you were using postgres or sqlite
so by creating a standard sql database
middleware we can simplify the process
not only of database vendors
implementing flight but also as users
that you have a standard sql
middleware for connecting to for example
you know postgres or another uh sql
database system and you get the you get
the results of your queries back to you
in arrow format
so the arrow r package uh wraps the
sequels plus api um using cpp11 you can
install it from cran
like you would um any other r package
we've labored very hard to to make this
uh possible and seamless but if you're
interested in following following the
upstream development we also have a
nightly package builds that you can
that you can install and get access to
the latest features and we are always
interested
these are not production releases but we
are always interested in having
folks from the from the our community
engaged in the development process
giving us feedback on what's broken like
what's not working well what's slow like
what sorts of features they would like
to see
um and the the major releases as i'm
about to to mention um are about to
about to tell you about are a little bit
slower a little bit more conservative so
getting using the the nightly builds for
developer uh for developers
uh can you can give us a faster feedback
if you're comfortable being on the
bleeding right bleeding edge and seeing
your your our uh our interpreter crash
occasionally
um
all right so
releases of releases of arrow we started
the project in 2016
and we
um
there were 17 major releases up until
our 1.0 release at which point we
declared the aero format
stable
and we moved to semantic versioning so
you you maybe have seen that the version
numbers are starting to go up uh more
aggressively and that's because we've
moved to a semantic versioning
versioning model um
and so we do coordinated releases of
most of the language libraries and
bindings that includes that includes the
r package so when you see the 5.0
version of pyro and the 5.0 version
of of of the r package those we we
intend for the versions uh to to roughly
correspond to each other um and so while
they're you know there are some you know
new changes uh and and non-backwards
compatible changes that occur at the api
at the api level at the arrow format
levels things remain things remain
stable
0.14 in 2019 was the first cran release
and over time we've we've steadily been
adding new features uh to the r library
which i'll show you some of the new the
new features that we have
um
and we've worked to make the
installation process more seamless while
bringing you as much out of the box
functionality um as we can without you
having to get into the details of how to
build and attain the very you know the
many you know the growing number of
dependencies that the aero package has
in our
so
one of the the major growth areas and
and focuses of the r package development
is that we want to provide really
seamless integration with dplyr and and
the tidy verse
this hasn't come all at once so we've
had to to implement deep plier verbs um
on a
on a bit by bit basis and that's because
we are working to implement this
computational functionality
in the r in the r package itself uh so
in the 0.16 release we we released the
very preliminary support
for uh for the select and filter filter
commands
uh in in d plier
um
in on the 2.0 release we brought amazon
s3 support so if you have data that
lives in parquet format in an s3 bucket
you can
directly access that data using the
arrow package and query that data with
uh with with the dplyr api
using that using that that support
in the 4.0 release earlier this year we
we dropped support for mutate and
arrange
we're of course
working to add as much
as much feature coverage in terms of
what you can do inside
of these functions so that we have
provide mappings between
because we're executing
our expressions natively on arrow data
format which is not the same as ours
data frame format and so whenever you
have uh because these are all
non-standard evaluation expressions in r
so when you write an r expression we
have to map the r function onto the
corresponding arrow function
and if you use an r function that we
don't support um you may get an error
and then you can open a bug report and
or a feature request
maybe a better way to put it and we can
implement that function and provide the
mapping in the in the r library so you
get seamless uh seamless uh dplyr
querying capability
um since 4.0 and 5.0 we've rapidly
expanded the functions that are
supported from within the dplyr verbs to
now more than 250 250 functions that
number continues to expand continues to
expand rapidly and very excitingly for
people who are
who want to crunch very large data sets
in the 6.0 release which is coming up
later this fall we will finally have
support for summarizing group by which
will unlock
a lot of interesting workloads on very
large very large data sets
so to give you a sense of like how how
all of this uh how all of this works and
how the pieces
how the pieces fit together so this is
the base the baseline
this this example shows you the baseline
performance of dplyr uh on an r data
frame so here we're using the arrow read
parquet function to read a single
parquet file um the as data frame
argument
asks arrow to turn the arrow data into
an r data frame and then everything from
after this point um everything from
after this point is using dplyer on our
data frames to crunch to crunch the
files so we have a 10 million row
parquet file 250 megabytes it this uses
a lot of the major d plier verbs and
this runs in about 1.6
1.6 seconds
so if you
um if you set as data frame false when
you read the parquet file then the data
is read into memory as an arrow table
instead which is a more memory it's a
more compact and memory efficient
representation
of the data in many cases
and the arrow format is really optimized
for processing numeric data as well as
string data so you see a lot of
efficiency benefits
when processing a lot of a lot of string
data
but here we use all of the same dplyr
verbs
uh as we did in the the r data frame
example and at the very end when you
call collect it's at that point that the
arrow data that's output from the the
last deployer verb is converted to an r
data frame and so changing just from
the r data frame format to the arrow
arrow format we go from 1.6 seconds to
0.6 seconds on the same on the same data
file so we get a lot more so we get a
lot more efficient processing as well as
a lot less memory use so if you look at
the memory footprint of this operation
the aero version uses significantly less
memory
now let's ratchet up uh you know ratchet
up the data set size so uh suppose you
have not just one parquet file but a ton
like a hundred or here i have 125
parquet files so now we're not talking
250 megabytes uh it's 40 gigabytes of
parquet files spread across 125 files 2
billion rows
and so arrow has the special open data
set function which allows you to address
partitioned directories
of of parquet files or csv files
and then you can query a collection of
of these files using the same declire
interface
exactly as you would a single r data
frame or a single arrow table
and what's uh exciting about this is
that we analyze these expressions and
use them to
to prune files from having to be scanned
or to do filtering within the files to
limit the amount of data that we have to
decode into
into arrow format and so that enables us
to do direct querying on these extremely
large data sets while pulling very
little data into memory and so we're
able to evaluate this dplyr expression
on a 40 gigabyte data set in a little
over one second
and this is partly fast because arrow is
fast but it's also taking advantage of
the static analysis of these dplyr
expressions to not scan more data than
we need to
it's very exciting
some new
functionality that's dropping i know i'm
running out of time so i'll go quickly
through this but if you've heard of the
duckdb project uh another a very
exciting analytic
analytic database process analytic
database project um you can seamlessly
transfer data into into duct db and use
ductdb for querying so here when you use
the 2duckdb function it returns a db
plier object and so subsequent dplyer
expressions are getting translated into
sql
by dplyr and then allowing ductdb to
uh to process uh to process the data
and ductdb has very comprehensive sql
functionality
and supports a lot of query query
processing that arrow does not yet
support yet and so this can help you
help you in your work and the cool thing
here is that it it composes very
naturally with all of the other aero
machinery including the aero dataset
machinery so you get to reap the
benefits of both worlds
so we're working uh you know very
actively to bring
comprehensive uh querying capability
natively within the aeroc plus libraries
which will
be made available to our programmers
through the dplyr deep player interface
so you can see you'll you can expect to
see more of these coming in subsequent
releases so i expect we'll have a lot
more
to talk about a year from now and i look
forward to sharing all of those
improvements with
uh with you
um
since you know some of you use python
and r so you might say well where's all
you know when did the python programmers
get to join in on all of the fun
and some of you may be familiar with a
project called ibis which i would
describe as a kind of d plier-like
project for
for python and so we are working to
enable the same kind of dplyr-like
querying ability uh using the the ibis
project which enables the same kind of
static analysis of expressions that we
have uh in dplyr uh from from python
so
um so this being said there you know
there are you know many uh query engines
in development that know how to process
aero the data fusion project is written
in rust
and
so that's another aero query engine
project you can you can take a look into
my team
you know our team at voltron is very
focused on
the uh cpus plus project and its
interfaces in python and r um but we are
working to deliver uh fluent computing
interfaces um in you know in in multiple
programming languages so we will expand
beyond python and r in the future
so a kind of to last last item to leave
you with before i i leave since i've
i've overstayed my welcome
but one of the problems we're working
actively right now to address is the
problem of fragmented user interfaces to
different back-end computing engines so
some engines speak sql some some systems
have their own interfaces like dplyr and
ibis
and that creates this like you know
paired up point-to-point problem of like
how do these query front-ends
communicate with all of these different
query back-ends um and that and that
creates a lot of headache for users
because you have to think like okay what
api do i want to use to communicate with
this compute backend
um so we are working uh you know with a
a bunch of
a bunch of open source developers to
define and
and specify
an intermediate compute representation
which can bridge the gap between these
different front-end interfaces whether
data frame interfaces default dplyr
and uh and back-end so that you can
choose the api that suits you best and
you can drive
as many different compute engines as you
have
available to you without having to
significantly rewrite your code this
will obviously take a long time to
deliver but something we're very uh
we're very excited about
so we're in the aero community we're
actively discussing this we've been
begun to collaborate with folks outside
of the aero community
to create a common compute
representation
to bridge front ends to back ends
and so we expect that this will be an
important uh kind of element of the
future growth of the ecosystem so if
you're interested in this there's a new
open source initiative called substrate
uh you know we're involved in this and
we hope to enlist more folks from the
community
in making this a reality
so thanks again for uh for for having me
and i look forward to seeing you
hopefully in person
next year
but otherwise you know we we we love to
hear from you in the aero arrow
community and we look forward to
continuing to power up data science and
r so thanks thanks again
so you heard it west has already
confirmed for next year so good he'll be
in eight years in a row so you gotta
make sure dan chen is there as well and
ready to do that